So the name Hadoop comes from my son's toy
elephant. When he was about two, a friend gave
him a little stuffed elephant which he played with
incessantly. and we overheard him calling it something, this
strange word that he invented. and said Hadoop. So
I, I immediately wrote it down because I was
in the, the software business. And we're always looking
for good names. And this one came with a, a
mascot, even. and a few years later when I
needed a project name, pulled it out. Now I,
I wrote it down as H A D O O P. And figured that everyone would say Hadoop. Now
it turns out everyone says Hadoop instead, but I persist in saying
Hadoop. Now my son, of course, is 13, and expects
royalties for the name. He he wants more credit. He also accuses me of stealing
the toy. At some point, he was using it in some kind of rocket ship experiment,
and I had to rescue it. And now it, it lives in my sock drawer for, for safety.